[Music]
ask a lot of questions
because the more information you have
the more the more power that you will
have
compensation
has a lot more elements to it
typically than
most people identify at senior levels
a compensation package is going to have
maybe as many as eight or ten
major
components
we tend to think about
base salary
cash incentive bonus and equity grants
kind of
the big three
but there's
relocation
you know allowances home buying programs
you know
pension gross ups signing bonuses
special
project based
in incentive options and as many things
as people can can can dream up so the
first thing you want to you want to do
when you're in a comp compensation
discussion with anybody is find out how
many of those elements might possibly
come into play
you know do you have project-based
bonuses do you you know do you use
signing bonuses do you you know how do
you award you know option option grants
if i'm relocating how do you deal with
relocation is a home buyout part of that
blah blah blah and so now you've got
a framework of
of what's possible and there might be
something on that list
that could be really really valuable
to you
um
if you go to work for stanford your kids
get to get to go to stanford i mean
if you got college-age kids i mean i
know people who have stayed here because
of that that's huge
you know and so
find out what the list is and then the
other the other thing i i tell people
um
a compensation discussion is a little
bit like working at a mixing board in a
sound studio you ever see these things
they got all these they're trying to
manage the sound probably there's a guy
back there behind the wall doing that
right now and you got about 10 levers
that that you know various
levels of the sound
you can't push them all to maximum
because you just get garbage it's the
same thing in a compensation discussion
you can't push everything to maximum but
you can probably push something
and one of the things that
is i tell people try to find the soft
money
if there is any i mean maybe
the individual you're talking to has a
severe salary cap and they just can't
go any higher
but they've got a lot of discretion
on a signing bonus
well money's money okay so you don't get
and so maybe you don't get that extra
twenty five or fifty thousand dollars in
salary but you pick up a hundred
thousand dollar signing bonus well
that's pretty good because you can have
a salary negotiation again
in
a year but maybe you can negotiate it to
six months
um and and get a review in six months
again what's the review cycle that's one
of the items on the list people don't
tend to think about so
you know
recognize at the end of the day that if
you push
too many of the levers
you you could blow the deal
but you can push some and people expect
you to push somebody they they're i
think particularly um
uh impressed
if you do it intelligently
particularly if you push something
that's not one of the one of the top
three and if you've done your homework
first off i mean at a minimum if you're
replacing somebody you should be able to
get everything that that individual got
because that's already been approved in
the system so that's a starting point
and and usually if you ask
you can find out what that is
if you know what industry counterparts
that their competitors get for the same
job that's useful information
and so again do your homework figure out
what the elements are push the the the
one
that in in particular is worth more to
you to get than it is to them to give it
to you and that's where you can really
if you push on something where they're
resisting
that's going to be hard so go find go
find somewhere else so it's it's another
version of an open door but it's just go
go find something that's easy as opposed
to fighting over something that's hard
and i mean at the end of the day
i always
try to encourage
people in that negotiation
to try to get the company to accept that
you want to bet on your own performance
so go for
bigger upside on bonuses
shorter reviews project bonuses okay
i'll go in at this level it's a little
less than than what i want
uh in terms of salary but given that
uh is it possible that i i can have a
review of six months
and if the performance warrants i get
that adjustment
that's pretty soft they're not giving
much they're not giving away any money
they may well they may well agree to
that and if and if you perform then you
get it in six months if you don't
perform you're not going to get it
anyway
[Music]